this past weekend I hosted my first
event over a hundred people came here to
bath for Simon cycom Khan and
it was completely overwhelming
[Music]
thank you
the event went really really well I
don't actually think we could have asked
for it to have gone any better had some
amazing feedback from people on the day
people at the end came up to me and said
how much they enjoyed it and how much
they took away from the talks and the
panels that we had and how most of all
they just enjoyed meeting other people
of this community and making new friends
so we hit our objectives I think it's
fair to say that if you couldn't make it
to this event
I'll probably do another event like this
probably in the UK at some point in the
future though not for a few months at
least please and if that next event goes
well maybe we could look at doing
something outside of the UK maybe
actually making the event a bit more
ambitious and making it not just about
my YouTube channel for me the day was a
complete blur if you've been married you
might know this feeling of you spend
months working up to your wedding day
doing all this preparation and then on
the day you're kind of on Rails like you
know this thing's happening this thing
this thing this thing and things happen
to you it almost feels like you don't
really have all that much agency but
then you have these conversations with
with you know like a hundred people and
you get to talk to everyone in some
detail it's only afterwards that I think
it really hits you like you kind of
process it all at once which is what I
did I sat down afterwards and I was just
like
thank you so much to everybody who came
some of you traveled internationally to
this event and I was just so wonderful
to meet you as I said on the day this
wasn't an event that I about me it was
an event about you there's this
community of people so I can't thank you
enough for being there particular thanks
must also go to the organizing committee
people from the community who
volunteered their time to make this
event possible cat danvy cap Allen it
simply wouldn't have been possible
without your work thank you so much
thanks also to the RP Geeks for
providing an incredibly chaotic one hour
one shot which was uh
[Applause]
yeah about what I expected and also
thank you to some of the moderators from
the Discord who volunteered came to Bath
just to Shepherd people around and make
sure the event ran smoothly thank you so
much by the way we have a Discord in
case you didn't know there's a there's a
link down there in the description this
past weekend felt like a milestone like
a kind of a culmination of my work to
date and actually it just so happens
that the event purely by chance
coincided almost exactly with this
YouTube channel reaching half a million
subscribers which how do you even begin
to process that although this is only
possible I've only had the amazing
opportunities I've had and I've only
been able to do this job because of you
the people who watch my videos in the
community that's built up around them
and the two words that I said most
frequently over the weekend were thank
you and I'm going to repeat them to you
now thank you so much for giving me this
extraordinary job and the opportunities
that I've had trust that I am always
aware of how lucky I am to do this I
just said that this all felt like kind
of a milestone in my life but it also
feels like a a critical point like a
turning point in my life because behind
the scenes there's a lot of stuff going
on there's some new projects and New
Opportunities and a lot of new videos
that I'm working on almost all of which
I can't talk about yet though one
project I can tell you about is that
this week I launched a podcast how to
make a science video in which myself and
Sophie Ward who you may know from soap's
notes talk to science creators on
YouTube about how they do their job so
how they choose their topics how they
write their scripts how they design
thumbnails and titles all that kind of
thing the first two episodes talking to
tirzu and Simone yet are available right
now Wherever You cast your pods and all
the episodes of the first season that's
10 episodes are available on nebula
right now so if you have a nebula
subscription then you can listen to all
the episodes otherwise all 10 episodes
with guests like Tibby's and Brian from
real engineering and Angela Collier will
be coming out one a week but like I say
there's so much going on behind the
scenes that I still can't talk about and
it feels like my work and frankly my
life are entering a new phase the main
reason I wanted to make this video was
because of this turning point because of
all this stuff that's going on in the
background I wanted to give myself a
chance to make a thesis statement to try
and explain I guess in just a couple of
words what I am trying to accomplish
which is something that I wrote in the
keynote for the event and I feel like
it's useful for me and hopefully for you
to say this online as well in all my
work I am trying to enact positive
change on the most important issue in
the world on the climate crisis and I
think the best use of my talents such as
they are is making climate science more
accessible to people with the intention
that that will help people make more
inform decisions in their lives and
crucially in how they vote up until now
I focused on improving people's
understanding of the physical climate
system and how scientists talk about it
because that's my wheelhouse that's
exactly my academic background I'm still
going to make videos about that going
forward but I think I want to focus a
bit more now on how climate and climate
science intersect with our lives so
trying to focus a bit more on the
tangible that's not to say that I'm only
going to make projects about climate
going forwards I think there's a big
advantage to being a scientist or a
science communicator and not just
focusing on one thing but to summarize
the ethos I guess of what I'm trying to
accomplish in just a few words I'm
trying to improve people's climate
literacy and help them make informed
decisions
so while things may change a little bit
going forwards and perhaps you'll notice
some changes in the stuff that I do
that's the idea that's what I'm trying
to accomplish I'm really looking forward
to making these projects and as I said
before I'm just so grateful that I have
the opportunity to do this and I only
have this opportunity because of you
lovely people and actually in some cases
that's very literal if you support me on
my patreon then you are quite literally
financing these new projects if you
didn't know I have a patreon where you
get access to videos early you have some
Say in video topics that I choose and
you get access to exclusive behind the
scenes content a monthly Vlog that Luke
doesn't absolutely kill a job on so if
you missed my Vlogs then they're on my
patreon the names that were scrolling
past for this whole time by the way were
my executive producer patrons who
support me at the top tier thank you so
so much that's all I had for you today I
just wanted to reflect on the craziness
of the past weekend and take a moment
pause reflect before moving on to this
new phase thank you again for coming to
the event thank you as always for your
support of my work and if you want to
support this video you know what to do
you can like and comment and share it
all that kind of thing and I just leave
me say thank you for watching I'll see
you in the next one